ans
[Musique]
salut maroni prêt pour la découverte du
jour
aujourd'hui un dispositif super pratique
pour les élèves et les étudiants
porteurs de handicap grâce à cette aide
du département ils peuvent se rendre à
leurs cours en toute sérénité
si vous aussi cette tête vous intéresse
alors suivez-moi
[Musique]
nous sommes ici à saint gilles pour y
rencontrer un jeune étudiant adrien est
porteur d'un handicap depuis maintenant
10 ans grâce à l'aide du transport
scolaire du département il peut se
rendre tous les jours à l'université du
tampon et suivre son cursus dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
bonjour adrien 30 jours alors grâce au
département tu peux te rendre tous les
jours des cours à la fac au tampon
explique nous comment ça se passe alors
tous les matins j'ai mon chauffeur
attitré qui est pas ce que me chercher
6h45 et après ensuite on se rend à la
fac au tampon donc du coup on fait le
trajet saint gilles tampon et ça dure à
peu près 45 minutes en fonction du
trafic et ça fait combien de temps que
tu utilises ce dispositif ça va bientôt
faire dix ans le niveau des avantages
supplémentaires que tu as grâce à cette
aide au transport ça permet à mes
parents de plus penser à est ce que il
faut l'emmener
est-ce qu'ils ont la disponibilité ou
pas et du coup ça permet d'avoir une
charge en moins eh bien merci adrien
merci à vous
[Musique]
cette aide au transport scolaire n'est
pas seulement destiné aux étudiants tous
les élèves qui ne peuvent pas utiliser
les réseaux publics sont éligibles le
dispositif s'adapte aux contraintes et
aux besoins de chaque famille
bonjour madame mayrand vengeurs alors
quelles sont les démarches nécessaires
pour obtenir cette tête du département
alors pour obtenir cette aile il faut
d'abord demander une notification de
transport auprès de la maison
départementale des personnes en
situation de handicap et ensuite remplir
un formulaire d'inscription pour
inscrire son enfant dans notre
dispositif et quel est l'objectif de ce
dispositif donc ces dispositifs a deux
objectifs un premier objectif où on va
indemniser les familles qui souhaitent
amener leurs enfants avec leur propre
véhicule ou les abonnements de
transports scolaires et urbains et dans
un deuxième temps on met en place des
transports avec des taxis
et des véhicules aménagés ce transport
adapté de quelle manière et s'il
favorise l'inclusion et la scolarisation
de ses élèves donc pour les élèves qui
utilisent le transport on s'adapte au
plus près de l'emploi du temps et d'une
autre part on favorise l'inclusion
l'accompagnant les élèves vers leur lieu
de stage pour leur permettre une
découverte du monde du travail merci
madame mayrand merci beaucoup
et grâce à ce dispositif de transport
les élèves et les étudiants porteurs de
handicap peuvent poursuivre leur
scolarité ils peuvent atteindre leur
objectif réaliser leurs rêves cette
prise en charge individualisée et
spécifiques favorise leur inclusion à
l'école et dans la société bonjour
adrien bonjour alors comment se passent
les trajets au quotidien vers
l'université du tampon et ben très bien
le chauffeur et pour le temps à leur
super serviable d'accord ben écoute
merci beaucoup je te souhaite une bonne
continuation à une belle réussite
commerciale vous
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'information concernant l'aide au
transport scolaire des élèves et
étudiants handicapés n'hésitez pas vous
avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affiche sur votre écran le département
des générations c'est fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
dans le prochain épisode
je vous emmène découvrir le pass
transport grâce à ce dispositif les
personnes en situation de handicap
peuvent payer un taxi pour faire ses
courses ou pour se rendre chez le
médecin ils peuvent ainsi se déplacer en
toute autonomie
[Musique]